joined by delighted foreign office
minister james cleverly my goodness me
good day at the office yeah a good day a
good day and it's a culmination of a lot
of
work i mean people have been working on
this for four years uh previous foreign
secretaries previous
officials uh but yeah
yesterday was a really good day a really
good day you've been intimately involved
in the negotiations for a very long time
uh in in with the with your respective
job what have been the most challenging
aspects
well
you know for much of this we we
we found dealing with the iranian
government uh incredibly
difficult i think the change of
government has definitely helped
um
the
practicalities
of the uh of the logistics of getting
people home the negotiations of getting
nazanin out on furlough i mean it was
complicated
at every stage of course because of the
huge number of sanctions quite rightly
applied to iran all these things become
very very tricky very very difficult but
ultimately we you know we never gave up
we continued working we continued
supporting the families and i have to
say
my admiration for for the families of
all those uh detained in iran is is
enormous
and because of that continued teamwork
we we managed to secure the release of
um of three-day detainees and obviously
naznen and anushay get to come home as
well why did we not pay our debt 20
years ago as we were instructed to do by
the international court of arbitration
well one of the big problems of course
is because of iran's behavior because of
they because of things they have chosen
to do there are a huge number of
international
sanctions against them and uk sanctions
so it's technically not easy now we were
able to come to an arrangement at the
details of which i'm not allowed to
discuss they're confidential whereby we
can ensure that the money is for
humanitarian purposes only and that
we've been able to do a deal which does
fit within the international sanctions
regime that's imposed against iran yeah
but i suppose the question remains why
did we not pay the debt before now given
that we can pay it now and the sanctions
are still in place why didn't we pay it
sooner well as i say i can't go into the
details of the agreement but obviously
there are always two parties
or at least two parties to a negotiation
the previous iranian regime proved very
very difficult to deal with and some of
the proposals that we had put forward in
the past weren't accepted um the new
government coming in did give us an
opportunity to reset the foreign
secretary had the first face-to-face
meetings with her opposite number in
iran for the first time in over three
years i had a face-to-face meeting with
my opposition um again first time for
many many years and i think that was
part of a combination of things which
enabled us to to settle this
so is it right to say without going into
any detail that we had been trying to
pay the debt for some time but we'd come
up against roadblocks
we had been looking at ways to settle
the debt that we conceded that we owed
we we owed this debt we accepted that
debt obviously the sanctions position
made it incredibly difficult
you cannot just write a check doesn't
work like that now the details of how we
have done it of course as i say have to
remain confidential but it's taken a
huge amount of work to come up with a
method of ensuring that money is for
humanitarian purposes and that it
conforms to the sanctions that's my next
question how do we make sure that they
don't use it for arms well
as i say the the precise details of of
how we do this i'm not allowed to uh
discuss okay let me ask you a different
way how confident are you that they will
not be allowed to use it so we have
taken uh every precaution to make sure
that this is used exclusively for
humanitarian um uh requirements iran
does have a significant and meaningful
humanitarian requirement
and and as i say we have taken
precautions to to ensure that and how do
we make sure that uh future brits have
not put themselves in a more challenging
position because some would say this is
can be seen as a as a ransom payment
well look we've always said these things
uh were negotiated in parallel but they
were themselves
separate we owed this money it was money
that
as you say that we owed
so so that was one set of negotiations
about how we at how we did that but we
have always said the arrest
incarceration of all those british jew
nationals was unfair it was wrong it was
completely unjustified we've negotiated
very hard for many many years to get
them home we always tell people to pay
close attention to the uk travel advice
i think dual nationals are particularly
vulnerable in iran because iran does not
recognize dual nationality
but we will keep working to secure the
permanent release and return home of all
those unfairly detained yeah but the
release and the payment both came on the
same day so you know it's not
such a great leap to think that you know
it was a ransom payment well as i say we
have always made it clear that the money
was owed we recognise that we've been
looking at ways of doing that what
connections the iranian regime make is
up to them we have always been
completely clear that the incarceration
of british dual nationals was completely
wrong completely arbitrary completely
unfair and it has always been in iran's
gift
to release them the charges against them
were trumped up we've always said this
to be the case
um look but we're just really really
clear you see the images yeah no of
course but it's purely coincidental that
those two things happen same day as i've
as i've said
we have always made it clear that that
it is not linked but uh the iranians um
the iranians make the decisions that
they make
in response to the bilateral
relationship settling this debt and the
negotiations we've had with this new
iranian government have clearly been
more fruitful and i for one am just
incredibly pleased that we were able to
help families reunite okay was it
medical supplies how did we as i say
that there's there's there's
confidentiality okay um more we were
expecting morad to be on the plane as
well certainly that was the impression
we were given yesterday by the foreign
secretary what's happened there well no
we were we were
always trying to secure as i say the
full and permanent release of all the
british jewish nationals trying to get
them all home uh as the foreign sector
said in the house of commons yesterday
morad is a tri-national he's got
american citizenship as well that has
made it in the eyes of the iranians more
complicated than they are obviously uh
seeking to uh speak to the americans
about him as well we have and we will
continue to do everything we can to get
him home as well to his family you're
confident he'll be coming home well look
it's always very interesting he's the
only one of the three that is the only
one that was actually born in british i
know he's born in hammersmith i've
spoken i've spoken with i've spoken with
his
uh his family on a number of occasions
um we are going to keep working to get
him home to get him properly and fully
released well let's hope that is before
too long uh let's talk about saudi
arabia um has there been any sort of
breakthrough with the prime minister and
the saudis
well uh the the prime minister is
looking to help alleviate the pressure
that russia's invasion of ukraine has
had on oil and gas prices and we'll have
to see what the production levels that
come out of the middle east uh the you
know the prime minister has
a very influential relationship with a
number of heads of state and heads of
government
in the middle east and i really hope
that
um that that production will step up to
alleviate some of the pressure that
we're seeing but ultimately the prime
minister's right the best way to protect
ourselves against this kind of pressure
in the future is to make sure we
diversify our energy production we move
to renewable energy so we become less
reliant on all oil and gas particularly
oil and gas coming out of russia
81 people killed on a single day over
the weekend in saudi arabia three more
um killed uh yesterday we were told that
the prime minister brought up human
rights abuses when he was speaking to
the saudis it used to be a region that
you were particularly involved with
middle east minister of course what
particular human rights abuses would you
have wanted the prime minister to bring
up with the saudis well the uk has a
long-standing and in-principle
opposition to the death penalty we bring
that up when we speak with any country
that has the uh death penalty that would
have been brought up by the prime
minister it would have been brought up
with the prime minister i brought up
when i was the minister responsible for
our relationship uh with the middle east
i brought it up with those countries in
the middle east that retain the death
penalty
um and we do bring up uh human rights
more generally we defend human rights
defenders in the middle east including
in saudi arabia and we we do have
regularly very frank conversations with
them about this
we do of course need to maintain a
strong working relationship with saudi
it is a very significant and influential
country in the region and in the islamic
world but we do not hold back when we
have conversations with the saudis and
others about these issues what do we say
to them about the way they treat women
well we we have been um
critical about uh the the role of women
in saudi society i'm pleased to say
actually that over the last few years
there has been a huge liberalization in
the uh lives of women in saudi arabia
i've seen the change over the years that
i've been visiting we encourage them to
keep that going women you know are are
now i have to interrupt them from there
because i did see a video the other day
of all and you know i couldn't tweet it
because it was just disgusting a woman
who had allegedly committed adultery
um officials chopped her head off as she
was walking across the zebra crossing
with her child
i haven't seen that i can't comment on
that no but
trust me it illustrates how women some
women can be treated
as i say i'm very very uncomfortable i'm
very uncomfortable passing comment on a
video that i i haven't seen i don't know
the provenance of um the simple fact is
that the as i say the the liberalization
of the role of women in saudi has been
pacey we look to
amplify that we want that to um to
continue i've spoken and i've had
dealings with
senior women officials in the saudi
system that wouldn't have been the case
a number of years ago um we are we are
as i say we are always going to bring up
human rights issues when we speak okay
final thought about uh talking about
human rights final thoughts
with ukraine before i let you go um
it looks as though hundreds of people
were sheltering in a theater and
direct hit
bombed it looks as though they were
targeted that sounds to me like another
war crime well look we have we have seen
obvious targeting of civilian
infrastructure that's against
international humanitarian law it's
against the law of armed conflict uh
we've got to make sure that we capture
evidence of uh all these incidents so
that uh so that the the russian regime
that's conducting this completely
illegal completely unjustified war in
ukraine are held account by the
international courts once this is uh
once this is resolved and we will keep
applying pressure to choke off the
funding to the russian war machine to
try and bring this war to a conclusion
as quickly as possible